i'm going to start today with something
very
uh pithy and simple that
i know is going to get some of my
audience upset with me
and that's okay because we can disagree
i think
which is that barack obama former
president
was right to say that the defund the
police slogan
is not a good slogan and that it needs
to be completely
renamed and i'm actually reminded of the
ronald reagan
quote if you are explaining you were
losing
ronald reagan was correct and
republicans seem to get this this is one
of the biggest failures of the left if
you look at
the work of people like thomas frank and
and george lakoff in particular
about naming and framing and slogans the
left is
absolutely terrible at this and when you
have to
explain well when i said defund i meant
this other thing
you're already losing so let's kind of
go through it in layers
actually defunding and eliminating the
police as a big picture plan
doesn't make any sense it we've talked
about this before
it's not reasonable it's not practical
it's not going to happen in any uh
framework that we can imagine even
places that quote
have done it haven't really done it
sometimes they've just
separated up police departments into
different subgroups or units or whatever
the case may be
now some people are saying defund the
police but they mean something else
they mean you know will reform
mostly in some places will have fewer
police in others will demilitarize and
will change
how prosecution is done well now you're
explaining away a slogan
that doesn't really represent what you
mean so why are you using the slogan
anyway
and i've been talking about this since
day one of this
slogan during the george floyd protests
i put out
like a 10 or 12 point plan for how i
would reform the police
and many in my audience agreed with
demilitarization
uh training as social workers extending
police training periods
stopping what i call low effort policing
it's a very long list which you can go
back to and there were some in my
audience who furiously did not agree
with me
and i presume that those same folks
aren't going to like what barack obama
said
so what did barack obama say let's take
a look at that if
you believe as as i do that we should be
able to reform the criminal justice
system
so that it's not biased and treats
everybody
fairly i guess you can use a snappy
slogan like
defund the police but you know you've
lost a big audience the minute you say
it which makes it a lot less likely that
you're actually going to get the changes
you want done
but if you instead say let's reform the
police department
so that everybody's being treated fairly
you know divert
young people from getting into crime and
if there's a homeless guy
can maybe we send a mental health worker
there instead of
an armed unit that could end up
resulting in a tragedy
suddenly a whole bunch of folks who
might not otherwise listen to you
are listening to you so the key is
deciding do you want to actually get
something done
or do you want to feel good among the
people you already agree with
and if you want to get something done in
a democracy
in a country as big and diverse as ours
then you've got to be able to
meet people where they are and play a
game of addition and not subtraction
this is simply pragmatism and barack
obama actually lists many of the exact
same reforms that i suggested in my list
some months ago
barack obama is making the exact same
case that i made about actually getting
things done that's what i care about i
want to get things done
think about it in those terms there are
millions of people in the united states
who believe the police should be
reformed and you even have allies
on areas of the right on that idea you
have some on the libertarian right who
want to reform the drug policing
piece of police departments you have
some on the religious right
that want community programs rather than
prison for certain crimes
you have people like me on the left who
want to end the war on drugs and and
police militarization and solve the
problem of it being so difficult to hold
bad
actors accountable due to a system that
favors police when they're charged with
crimes and prevents this global
national bad actors database you know
all these different things you have all
these different people who
could conceivably work together on this
and then you have a tiny portion of
people who actually just want police
flatly defunded
and eliminated in some cases so if what
you
mean by defund is the things i mentioned
and the things that barack obama
mentioned then you simply lose potential
allies
when the slogan is defund the police and
the police
so i just don't have time when
things are so critical to be toying
around with slogans that are going
nowhere anyway
defund the police sounds like you're
saying
uh we should take funding away from
police who are
bad and do away with police as an
institution
now some people do think that if you're
somebody who thinks that
we just disagree most people don't think
that
they think something closer to my reform
plan
so by using the slogan you're
immediately trying to explain what you
really mean and that means that you're
losing
let me give you one further example one
of the things we need
are police officers from more diverse
backgrounds
and i'm not talking you know racially or
religiously or economically even
although that that would be good
i'm talking culturally you find that in
many
cities police are disproportionately
from conservative rural areas
outside the city one thing that will
help
fix police is more people who would do
the job the way
we want them to do the to do the job
people who are from and even live in
those cities now
typically the cities are more expensive
than the rural areas
so sometimes police being underpaid
and not being able people in cities
can't live in the cities on a police
salary
that's why you get people from the rural
conservative areas
coming in because they can come in and
then live in the cheaper areas
you might have to increase funding in
those cases for salaries
to get more cultural diversity in the
police department so
how does defund the police help achieve
that it doesn't
now there's a reasonable counterpoint
from uh
people including congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
who says you don't start with the safe
ask
you start with more and you negotiate
back
the problem with that is specifically
with a slogan like defund the police
tons of people tune out because it
sounds wacky it's not like hey listen
we'd like 22 bucks an hour
so we'll ask for it and we'll negotiate
down to 15 because everybody will
participate in the negotiation
no it's not we would love medicare for
all
but we would negotiate to a
strong public option to start and then
next year we come back with medicare for
all
if you want to get rid of police
altogether
you immediately get a rejection from a
lot of the people that are
in the reform and they see you as a
non-serious actor
and it stops the conversation so yes i
agree with president obama
i think he's absolutely right here and
we're going to damage our own ability to
fix the problems
that we've identified by using slogans
like defund when it's not what most
people mean and it's never going to
happen anyway
tell me where i'm wrong i'm ready to
have a bigger discussion about it
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently checked
out the book podcast marketing strategy
by daniel rolls
and kieran rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to
what i'm doing really recommend it
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video